voyager mission geht immer weiter die
raumsonde beute 1 wurde vor einer
gefühlten ewigkeit ins all befördert um
es ein wenig genauer zu sagen vor 38
jahren im september 1977 verließ die
sonde die erdatmosphäre
ihr eigentlicher auftrag war die
erforschung der planeten und monde im
äußeren bereich des sonnensystems
die reise ging allerdings weiter und im
august 2012 verließ die sonne dann als
erste unser sonnensystem drei jahre
später konnte die nasa das erstmals
bestätigen inzwischen ist die sonder
rund 21 milliarden kilometer von uns
entfernt eigentlich viel da wollte einst
war das gleiche wie das der reuter 2 die
16 tage zuvor gestartet war
diese sollte ebenfalls die planeten
saturn und jupiter genauer analysieren
nachdem dieses erfüllt war erweiterte
sich die zielvorgabe beute zwei wie
vorgänger sondern machte sich auf den
weg zum uranus und neptun jetzt haben
experten mit hilfe des
hubble-weltraumteleskops den weiteren
verlauf der volta missionen
durchleuchtet da die nächsten
meilensteine in der fernen zukunft
fliegen bis über 90 tausend jahren kann
aktuell nicht wirklich von einem
konkreten viel gesprochen werden die
energie der sonne reicht allerdings nur
noch für 10 jahre aus um daten an die
erde schicken zu können ihr flug geht
danach aber weiter
aber interessant kann es auf jeden fall
noch werden väter hat die wechselwirkung
zwischen einem stern und seiner
interstellaren umgebung sind besonders
aufschlussreich denn diese dynamischen
prozesse spielen sich um die meisten
sterne ab was rap viel von der
westlichen university in connecticut ihr
beschreibt werden die sonden aber
hoffentlich schon in den kommenden
jahren detaillierter untersuchen können
aktuell denen die sonden hauptsächlich
der analyse von interstellarem material
vorbei hat sich jemand von euch schon
mal versucht vorzustellen wie sich das
umfeld außerhalb unserer erde anhört das
was er jetzt gleich höher sind
tatsächlich tonaufzeichnung aus dem
weltall aufnahmen auf mehreren
milliarden kilometern entfernt
die geräusche von den plasma vibrationen
wurden von einer der leiter sonnen
zwischen oktober und november 2012 und
april mai 2013 aufgenommen wie ich finde
klingt das super spannend und verspricht
viele weitere meldungen wenn auch nicht
sofort nicht sofort aber schon morgen
gibt es hier auf die zum ein weiteres
video darf nicht zu verpassen
unbedingt hier klicken um uns kostenlos
zu abonnieren und bis dann dran